ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata piano terra
secondo pronto san guglielmo nei chiesto
di chiamarti fisico in vista proprio
tutti come la prima casa in bocca al
lupo per la tesi e poi una seconda
richiesta devo fare tutti ragazzi e
bentornati aveva puntato modello
incitarmi a studiare studia studia
studia le persone che non studiano la
fuori pensa a me tu non vuoi essere come
me che se fate non studiare psicologia
inversa che ti serve comunque la cultura
la cultura che è un'arma ma le armi
servono per combattere la vita non
dovrebbe essere una guerra quindi più di
quel libro esci fuori
vai al parco perdi anni della tua vita
arriva a 40 anni sentendosi un fallito
una fallita perché perché a vivere un
sogno avresti voluto tagliare un
traguardo che ti eri prefissato non ci
sei riuscita ad essere quattro bambini
un matrimonio finito alle spalle è un
ponte che chiami casi studia più smorfie
possibili in 30 secondi
cerco di copiare tutte le mose almeno so
già che smarcare via
sarà un'opera me volevo fare molto
meglio però insomma fate un mini torneo
di chi ride prima perde tratto gianmarco
ed enrico tosse forza ti ricordo nel
william senza eta beta
no no no dobbiamo dare creare il pd
pronti reset mazzarri nello sistema così
martina così riguardanti i ragazzi di a
io l'avevo riso
ai lavori ripete quello non stava
rivolgere anche io bene voi non avete
giocato mi ha dato la forza del sud
sparire legge la sua faccia che proprio
secondo e terzo posto ma di moroni
malaccio
no non puoi fare dai e vile l'occhiolino
3321 via io non ho visto diventato il
replay è la battuta con quest'occhio si
vede ho fatto posto con quest'occhio per
farlo non bisogna farlo però a farne una
senza da retrocede più già mi fai stare
in piedi una scopa e ricoh alza di voi
non lo vede primo suv centro stile ma
quand'è che l'asse terrestre invece si
mette in un inclinazione tale da pulirmi
casa se lascio la scopa da sola spiega c
la vera storia del dipinto di maria
raboni l'aspetto da 11 anni possiamo
avere il dipinto che ancora a casa mia
ma questo è maria raboni un quadro che
un'amica e dico fare macello lo sta
cancellando sto quadro che un'amica
pittrice di mia madre che mi ha dato
anche delle elezioni in passato molto
molto brava ha dipinto mirate si è
innamorata subito tanto che questa sua
amica gli aveva regalato ha visto che
vediamo maira poveri in canna
i soldi per permetterselo tuttora non li
abbiamo un gesù che non a caso ricorda
leggermente marco mengoni ma la pittrice
era anche una talent scout da cosa lo
capisce dal microfono che tiene in mano
un gesto benedicente nei confronti di
una donna che appoggia la sua testa su
un piatto ha finito di mangiare maria
rabuni cosa vuol dire rabuni cerchiamolo
insieme paragoni titolo onorifico
ebraico rabbi conservato ad esempio
nell'italiano rabbino è il suo sinonimo
è come se fosse il giapponese del gian
marco sanna enrico san maria sanna maria
raboni personalmente tengo così tanto a
questo quadro che non vedo l'ora di
darlo via
se avete voglia di partecipare all'asta
chiamate il numero in sovrimpressione
base di partenza 10 mila euro grazie
canta godzilla di eminem come valuto
prenderti il tackle wi fi batte il
record mondiale di velocità di rep
ma è proprio bravo invero nelle miniere
manzo qualità meno in media il tuo
telecomando mentre è imminente ma te
cosa meno bene
vedere ma magari perché no fare ben da
enrico e fargli indovinare degli oggetti
vieni mani braccialetto no no orecchino
il cuore tuo sulla scrivania gancio il
da roma sulla libreria bravissimo non so
se è pollo carne carne di manzo carne da
te qualcosa per prime le mani carta
allora penso sia un uovo ma potrebbe
essere un inganno è un uovo per dio
ma che cos'è è una macchina fotografica
la spugnetta per lavare i piatti
bravo scrivi il tuo nome su un foglio
mettendo la penna dentro ad una narice
in pratica scrivi col naso a posto a 32
anni mettere una fa ste cose ragazze
sono sinistro destro un controllo un
cervello
vabbè marco male cioè il suo perché non
ci sono adesso non posso metterlo fino
al cervello dovrà fare raccapricciante
[Risate]
scrivi una poesia e dedica la enrico a
facciamo una cosa junmin ne scriviamo
una testa voti il vincitore
oddio potrebbero riscrivere una iq che
l'alba sorge tulipani si schiudono io
muoio
sono uno che sa fare bene fatto per
chiudere una quartina agosto in una
partita delle lettere il tempo e questo
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa come lo staff alla
pa pa pa pa pa non mi devi fare tu no
nel senso per farti capire la lunghezza
cretino non è che se un rapper una
quartina era stata detta una quartina
manzoni io non ho niente
la polizia di san marco
il titolo è riso babà al rum babà al rum
con pizzetto e codino tricheco foca
bambino degli abissi sguardo vispo e
riso cristallino mangiassi una volta sto
riso non si sa mai dimagrisse e riso in
questo caso è proprio il rischio più sul
classico e più sul pathos mai enrico al
mio caro cugino enrico ti amo e ti odio
ma in fondo sei mio amico 6 l'essenza
che ci lega col passato un dinosauro
lento che si muove con passato ti sarò
sempre grato per tutto avvio il
convoglio
ma
io penso che entrambe siano notti siano
notte lo penso anch'io gianmarco
veramente complimenti sorpreso fa
decisamente ragazzi secondo voi se vince
riso o grazie a impara dire ciao sono
guglielmo come va in polacco
chester williams di atleti church yes
the wheel miac le c medico un altro in
polacco henley con lug ies tv no enrico
lupi iescum no chissà cosa avrà detto
raiola tutti i commenti e tore impazzire
quindi sapere magari ho pronunciato male
è però una verità tramontare la prima
canzone disney che ti viene in mente ora
piani a un otorinolaringoiatra ora vieni
con me
verso un mondo di incanto principessa e
tanto che il tuo cuore aspetta un sì
metti un pollice in su
lascia anche un commento iscriviti al
canale da che aspetti i patti prete da
chi aspetti unisciti anche tu
2 credo sia il momento di chiudere
questo guglielmo tell
spero che vi siate divertiti come sempre
grazie mille per i vostri commenti se
volete contribuire a quello che facciamo
scriveteci delle idee qua sotto o
seguitemi su instagram perché la maggior
parte li prendo da lì detto ciò ci
vediamo questa domenica con una puntata
di cucina buttata alle 12 altrimenti non
so quando avremo un altro puglia e
modella che ne fino allora adios amigos
ti pensavo di fare capito un'uscita di
scena